[Music]
[Applause]
good evening and welcome to the Sony
Center for Performing Arts please note
during tonight's presentation video
audio and flash photography is
prohibited and we have a strict
zero-tolerance policy for any heckling
or disruptions
and now please welcome your host and
moderator president of Ralston college
dr. Stephen Blackwood
thank you a warm welcome to all of you
here this evening both those here in the
feeder in Toronto and those following
online you know it's not very often that
you see a country's largest theater
packed for an intellectual debate but
that's what we're all here for tonight
please join me
please join me in welcoming to the stage
dr. Slavoj Zizek
and dr. Jordan Peterson
just a few words of introduction there
can be few things I think now more
urgent and necessary in an age of
reactionary partisan Allegiance and
degraded civil discourse then real
thinking about hard questions the very
premise of tonight's event is that we
all participate in the life of thought
not merely opinion or prejudice but the
realm of truth access through evidence
and argument but these two towering
figures of different disciplines and
domains share more than a commitment to
thinking itself
they are both highly attuned to
ideologies and the mechanisms of power
and yet they are not principally
political thinkers they are both
concerned with more fundamental matters
meaning truth freedom so it seems to me
likely we will see tonight not only deep
differences but also surprising
agreement on deep questions dr. Slavoj
Zizek is a philosopher he has not one
but two doctoral degrees one in
philosophy
[Applause]
what in philosophy from the University
of Ljubljana and a second in
psychoanalysis from University let's
hear it for psychoanalysis from the
University of Paris 8 he is now a
professor at the Institute of sociology
and philosophy at the University of
Ljubljana and the director of the
Berbick Institute for the Humanities at
the University of London he has
published more than three dozen books
many on the most seminal philosophers of
the 19th and 20th centuries
he is a dazzling theorist
with extraordinary range a global figure
for decades he turns again and again
with dialectical power to radical
questions of emancipation subjectivity
and art
[Applause]
dr. Jordan Peterson is an academic and
critical
[Applause]
an academic and clinical psychologist
his doctorate was awarded by McGill
University and he was subsequently
we got some new girl gap graduates out
here he was subsequently professor of
psychology at Harvard University and
then the University of Toronto where he
is today the author of two books and
well over a hundred academic articles
dr. Peterson's intellectual roots
likewise lie in the 19th and early 20th
centuries where his reading of Nietzsche
Dostoyevsky and above all Karl Hume
inform his interpretation of ancient
myths of 20th century totalitarianism
and especially his endeavor to counter
contemporary nihilism his 12 rules for
life is a global bestseller and his
lectures and podcasts are followed by
millions around the world
[Music]
both doctors Dziedzic and Peterson
transcend their titles their disciplines
and the Academy just as this debate we
hope will transcend purely economic
questions by situating those in the
frame of happiness of human flourishing
itself we're in for quite a night a
quick word about format each of our
debaters will have 30 minutes to make a
substantial opening statement to lay out
an argument dr. Peterson first followed
by dr. G Jack each will then have in the
same order ten minutes to reply I will
then moderate 45 minutes or so of
questions many of which will come from
you the audience both here in Toronto
and online with that let's get underway
please join me in welcoming dr. Jordan
Peterson for the first opening statement
well thank you for that insanely
enthusiastic welcome for the entire
event and also for being here I have to
tell you first that this event and I
suppose my life in some sense hit a new
milestone that I was just made aware of
by a stagehand
today backstage who informed me that
last week the tickets for this event
were being scalped online at a higher
price than the tickets for the Leafs
playoff games so I don't know what to
make it out that's all right so how did
I prepare for this I went i familiarized
myself to the degree that it was
possible with Slava Boise Jack's work
and that wasn't that possible because he
has a lot of work and he's a very
original thinker and this debate was put
together in relatively short order and
what I did instead was returned to what
I regarded as the original cause of all
the trouble let's say which was the
Communist Manifesto and what I attempted
to do because that's Marx and we're here
to talk about Marxism let's say and what
I tried to do was read it and to read
something you don't just follow the
words and follow the meaning but you
take apart the sentences and you ask
yourself at this level of phrase and at
the level of sentence and that the level
of paragraph is this true
are there counter arguments that can be
put forward that are credible is this
solid thinking and I have to tell you
and I'm not trying to be flippant here
that I have rarely read a track now I
read it when I was 18 it was a long time
ago right that's 40 years ago but I've
rarely read a track that made as many
errors per sentence conceptual errors
per sentence as the Communist Manifesto
it was quite a miraculous reread it and
it was interesting to think about it
psychologically as well because
I've read student papers that were of
the same ilk in some sense although I'm
not suggesting that they were of the
same level of glittering literary
brilliance and polemic quality and I
also understand that the Communist
Manifesto was a call for revolution and
not a standard logical argument but
doubt notwithstanding I have some things
to say about the author's
psychologically the first thing is that
it doesn't seem to me that either marks
or Engels grappled with one fundamental
with this particular fundamental truth
which is that almost all ideas are wrong
and so if you and it doesn't matter if
they're your ideas or someone else's
ideas they're probably wrong and even if
they strike you with the force of
brilliance your job is to assume first
of all that they're probably wrong and
then to assault them with everything you
have in your arsenal and see if they can
survive and what what struck me about
the communist manifesto was it was akin
to something young said about typical
thinking and this was the thinking of
people who weren't trained to think he
said that the typical thinker has a
thought it appears to them like an
object might appear in a room the
thought appears and then they just they
just accept it as true they don't go the
second step which is to think about the
thinking and that's the real essence of
critical thinking and so that's what you
try to teach people in university is to
read a text and to think about it
critically not to destroy the utility of
the text but to separate the wheat from
the chaff and so what I tried to do when
I was reading the communist manifesto
was to separate the wheat from the chaff
and I'm afraid I found some wheat yes
but mostly chaff and I'm going to
explain why hopefully in relatively
short order so I'm going to outline ten
of the fundamental axioms of the
Communist Manifesto and so these are
truths that are basically held as
self-evident by the authors and they're
truths that are presented in some sense
as unquestioned and I'm going to
question them and tell you why I think
they're unreliable now we should
remember that this tract was actually
written 170 years ago that's a long time
ago and we have learned a fair bit from
since then about human nature about
society about politics about economics
there's lots of mysteries left to be
unsolved but left to be solved but we
are slightly wiser I presume then we
were at one point and so you can forgive
the authors to some degree for what they
didn't know but that doesn't matter
given that the essence of this doctrine
is still held as sacrosanct by a large
proportion of academics probably are
among the most what would you call
guilty of that particular sin so here is
proposition number one history is to be
viewed primarily as an economic class
struggle all right so so let's think
about that for a minute first of all is
there the proposition there is that
history is primarily to be viewed
through an economic lens and I think
that's a debatable proposition because
there are many other motivations that
drive human beings than economics and
those have to be taken into account
especially the drive people other than
economic competition like economic
cooperation for example and so that's a
problem
the other problem is that it's actually
not nearly a pessimistic enough
description of the actual problem
because history history this is to give
the devilís do the idea that one of the
driving forces between history is
hierarchical struggle is absolutely true
but the idea that that's actually
history is not true because it's deeper
than history its biology itself because
organisms of all sorts organize
themselves into hierarchies and one of
the problems with hierarchies is that
they tend to arrange themselves into a
winner-take-all situation and so but not
that is implicit in some sense in Marx
Marxist thinking because of course Marx
believed that in a capitalist society
but it would accumulate in the hands of
fewer and fewer people and that actually
is in keeping with the nature of
hierarchical organizations now the
problem with that is it so much the fact
of the so there's the there's accuracy
in the accusation that that is a eternal
form of motivation for struggle but it's
an underestimation of the seriousness of
the problem because it attributes' it to
the structure of human societies rather
than the deeper reality of the existence
of hierarchical structures per se which
as they also characterize the animal
kingdom to a large degree are clearly
not only human constructions and the
idea that there's hierarchical
competition among human beings there's
evidence for that that goes back at
least to the Paleolithic times and so
that's the next problem instead well the
this ancient problem of hierarchical
structure is clearly not attributable to
capitalism because it existed long in
human history before capitalism existed
and then it predated human history
itself so the question then arises why
would you necessarily at least
implicitly link the class struggle with
capitalism given that it's a far deeper
problem and now it's also you've got to
understand that this is a deeper problem
for people on the left not just for
people on the right it is the case that
hierarchical structures dispossessed
those people who are at the bottom those
creatures who are at the bottom
speaking say of animals but those people
who are at the bottom and that that is a
fundamental existential problem but the
other thing that Marx didn't seem to
take into account is that there there
are far more reasons that human beings
struggle then their economic class
struggle even if you build the
hierarchical idea into that which is a
more comprehensive way of thinking about
it human beings struggle with themselves
with the malevolence that's inside
themselves with the evil that they are
capable of doing with the spiritual and
psychological warfare that goes on
within them and we're also actually
always at odds with nature and this
never seems to show up in Marx and it
doesn't show up in Marx's Marxism in
general it's as if nature doesn't exist
the
primary conflict as far as I'm concerned
or a primary conflict that human beings
engage in is this struggle for life in a
cruel and harsh natural world and it's
as if it's as if that doesn't exist did
the Marxist domain if human beings have
a problem it's because there's a class
struggle that's essentially economic
it's like no human beings have problems
because we come into the life starving
and lonesome and we have to solve that
problem continually and we make our
social arrangements at least in part to
ameliorate that as well as to as to well
upon occasion exacerbated and so there's
also very little understanding in the
Communist Manifesto that any of the
likes a hierarchical organizations that
human beings have put together might
have a positive element and that's an
absolute catastrophe because
hierarchical structures are actually
necessary to solve complicated social
problems we have to organize ourselves
in some manner and you have to give the
devil his due and so it is the case that
hierarchies dispossessed people and
that's a big problem that's the
fundamental problem of inequality but
it's also the case that hierarchies
happen to be a very efficient way of
distributing resources and it's finally
the case that human hierarchies are not
fundamentally predicated on power and I
would say that biological
anthropological data on that or crystal
clear you don't rise to a position of
authority that's reliable in a human
society primarily by exploiting other
people it's a very unstable means of
obtaining power so so that's a problem
well the people that laughs might do it
that way
okay now the other another problem that
comes up right away is that Marx also
assumes that you can think about history
as a binary class struggle with clear
divisions between say the proletariat
proletariat and the Bruges huazi and
that's actually a problem because it's
not so easy to make a firm division
between who's exploiter and who's
exploiting let's say because it's not
obvious like in the case of small
shareholders let's say whether or not
they happen to be part of the oppressed
or part of the oppressor this actually
turned out to be a big problem in the
Russian Revolution and by big problem I
mean tremendously big problem because it
turned out that you could fragment
people into multiple identities and that
that's a fairly easy thing to do and you
could usually find some axis along which
they were part of the oppressor class it
might have been a consequence of their
education or it might have been a
consequence of their of their of their
of the wealth that they strived to
accumulate during their life or it might
have been a consequence of the fact that
they had parents or grandparents who
were educated too rich or that they're a
member of the priesthood or that they
were socialists or anyways that the
listing of how it was possible for you
to bieber's wha instead of proletariat
grew immensely and that was one of the
reasons that the Red Terror claimed all
the victims that had claimed and so that
was a huge problem
it was probably most exemplified by the
demolition of the kulaks who were
basically peasants peasant farmers
although effective ones in the soviet
union who had managed to raise
themselves out of serfdom over a period
of about forty years and to gather some
some degree of material security about
them and about 1.8 million of them were
exiled about four hundred thousand were
killed and the net consequence of that
removal of their private property
because of their burgeois status was
arguably the death of six million
Ukrainians in the famines of the 1930s
and so the binary class struggle idea
that was a bad idea that was a very very
bad idea it's also bad in this way and
that and this is a real sleight of hand
that Marx
office you have a binary class division
proletariat Bruce Wasi and you have an
implicit idea that all of the good is on
the side of the proletariat and all of
the evil is on the side of the
bourgeoisie and that's classic group
identity thinking you know it's one of
the reasons I don't like identity
politics is because once you divide
people into groups and pit them against
one another it's very easy to assume
that all the evil in the world can be
attributed to one group the hypothetical
oppressors and all the good to the other
and that well that's that's that's naive
that's naive beyond comprehension
because it's absolutely foolish to make
the presumption that you can identify
someone's moral worth with their
economic standing so and that actually
turned out to be a real problem as well
because Marx also came up with this idea
which is a crazy idea as far as I can
tell of the that's a technical term
crazy idea of the dictatorship of the
proletariat and that's the next idea
that I really stumbled across it was
like okay so what's the problem well the
problem is the capitalists own
everything they own all the means of
production and they're oppressing
everyone and that would be all the
workers and there's gonna be a race to
the bottom of wages for the workers as
the capitalists strive to extract more
and more value from the labor of the
proletariat by competing with other
capitalists should drive wages down word
which by the way didn't happen partly
because wages wage earners can become
scarce and that actually drives the
market value upward but the fact that
that you assume a priori that all the
evil can be attributed to the
capitalists and all the good that the
Barozzi and all the good could be
attributed to the proletariat meant that
you could hypothesize that a
dictatorship of the proletariat could
come about and that was the the first
stage in the Communist revolution and
remember this is a call for revolution
and not just revolution but bloody
violent revolution and the overthrow of
all overthrowing of all existent social
structures
um anyways the the the problem with that
you see is that because all the evil
isn't divided so easily up into
oppressor and oppressed that when you do
establish a dictator of the proletariat
to the degree that you can do that which
you actually can't because it's
technically impossible and an absurd
thing to consider to begin with not
least because of the problem of
centralization and you have to
hypothesize that you can take away all
the property of the capitalists you can
replace the capitalist class with a
minority of pro proletariat's how
they're going to be chosen isn't exactly
clear in the communist manifesto that
none of the people who are from the
proletariat class are going to be
corrupted by that sudden access to power
because they're well by definition good
so so then you have the good people who
are running the world and you also have
them centralized so that they can make
decision decisions that are insanely
complicated to make in fact impossibly
complicated to make and so that's a
failure conceptually on both dimensions
because first of all all the proletariat
aren't going to be good and when you
give put people in the same position as
the evil capitalists especially if you
believe that social pressure is one of
the determining factors of human
character which the Marxist certainly
believed then why wouldn't you assume
that the proletariat would immediately
become as or more corrupt than the
capitalist which is of course I would
say exactly what happened every time
this experiment was run and then
that the next problem is well what makes
you think that you can take some system
as complicated as like capitalist
free-market society and centralize that
and put decision-making power in the
hands of a few people the mechanisms by
without specifying the mechanisms by
which you're going to choose them like
what makes you think they're gonna have
the wisdom or the ability to do what the
capitalists were doing unless you assume
as Marx did that all of the evil was
with the capitalists and all the good
was with the proletariat's and that
nothing that capitalists did constituted
valid labor which is another thing that
Marx assumed which is palpably absurd
because people who are like maybe if
you're a dissolute aristocrat from 1830
and or earlier when you run a feudal
estate and all you do is spend your time
gambling and and and and chasing
prostitutes well then the your labor
value is zero but if you're if you're
running a business and it's a successful
business first of all you're a bloody
fool to it split exploit your workers
because even if you're greedy as sin
because you're not going to extract the
maximum amount of labour out of them by
doing that and the notion that you're
adding no productive value as a manager
rather than a capitalist is it's
absolutely absurd oh it does indicate
that you either know nothing whatsoever
about how an actual business works or
you refuse to know anything about how an
actual business works so that's
that's also a that's also a big problem
so then the next problem is the
criticism of profit it's like well
what's wrong with profit exactly what's
the problem with profit well the idea
from the Marxist perspective was that
profit was theft no but profit well can
be theft because crooked people can run
companies and so sometimes profit is
theft but that certainly doesn't mean
that it's always thrift what it means in
part at least if the capitalist is
adding value to the corporation then
there's some utility and some fairness
in him or her extracting the value of
their abstract labor their thought there
are abstract abilities their ability to
manage the company and to engage in
proper competition and product
development and efficiency and the
proper treatment of the workers and all
of that and then if they can create a
profit well then they have a little bit
of security for times that aren't so
good and that seems absolutely bloody
necessary as far as I'm concerned and
then the next thing is well how can you
grow if you don't have a profit and if
you have an enterprise that's valuable
and worthwhile and some enterprises are
valuable and worthwhile then it seems to
me that a little bit of profit to help
you grow seems to be the right approach
and so and then the other issue with
profit and you know this if you've ever
run a business is it it's really useful
constraint you know like it's not enough
to have a good idea it's not a good
enough to have a good idea and the sales
and marketing plant and then to
implement that and all of that that's
bloody difficult like it's not easy to
have a good idea and it's not easy to
come up with a good sales and marketing
plan and it's not easy to find customers
and satisfy them and so if you allow
profit to to constitute a limitation on
what it is that you might reasonably
attempt it provides a good constraint on
on wasted labour and so most of the
things that I've done in my life even
psychologically that were designed to
help people psychological health I tried
to run on a for-profit basis and the
reason for what that was apart from the
fact that I'm not averse to making a pro
but partly so my enterprises can grow
but was also so that there were forms of
stupidity that I couldn't engage in
because I would be punished by the
market enough to eradicate the
enterprise and so ok and then so the
next the next issue this is a weird one
so marks and angles also assume that
this dictatorship of the proletariat
which involves absurd centralization the
overwhelming probability of corruption
and impossible computation as the
proletariat now try to rationally
compute the manner in which an entire
market economy could run which cannot be
done because it's far too complicated
for anybody to think through the next
theory is that somehow the proletariat
dictatorship would become magically
hyper productive and there's actually no
theory at all about how that's going to
happen and so I had to infer the theory
and the theory seems to be that once you
eradicate the burgeois z because they're
evil and you get rid of their private
property and you you you you eradicate
the profit motive then all of a sudden
magically the small percentage of the
proletariat who now run the society
determine how they can make their
productive enterprises productive enough
so they become hyper productive now and
they need to become hyper productive for
the last error to be logically coherent
in relationship to the Marxist theory
which is that at some point the
proletariat the dictatorship of the
proletariat will become so hyper
productive that there'll be enough
material goods for everyone across all
dimensions and when that happens then
what people will do is spontaneously
engage in meaningful creative labor
which is what they had been alienated
from in the capitalist horrorshow and
the Utopia will be magically assured in
but there's no indication about how that
hyper productivity is going to come
about and there's no else
also no understanding that well that
isn't the utopia that is going to suit
everyone because there are great
differences between people when some
people are going to find what they want
in love and some are going to find it in
social being and some are going to find
it in conflict and competition and some
are going to find it in creativity as
Marx pointed out but the notion that
that that will necessarily be the end
goal for the utopian state is
preposterous and then there's the dusty
Espeon observe a Shinto which is one not
to be taken lightly which is what sort
of shallow conception of people do you
have that makes you think that if you
gave people enough bread and cake and
the Dostoyevsky in terms and nothing to
do with busy them to be except busy
themselves with the continued continuity
of the species that they would also all
of a sudden become peaceful and heavenly
Dostoyevsky's idea was that you know we
were built for trouble and if we were
ever handed everything we were we needed
on a silver platter the first thing we
would do is engage in some form of
creative destruction just so something
unexpected could happen just so we could
have the adventure of our lives and I
think there's something well there's
something to be said for that
so and then the last error let's say
although by no means the last was this
and this is one of the strangest parts
of the Communist Manifesto was marks it
agree admits and angles admit repeatedly
in the Communist Manifesto that there
has never been a system of production in
the history of the world that was as
effective at producing material
commodities in excess than capitalism
like that's that's extensively
documented in the communist manifesto
and so if your proposition is look we
got to get as much material security for
everyone as we as possible as fast as we
can and capitalism already seems to be
doing that at a rate that's unparalleled
in human history wouldn't the logical
thing be just to let the damn system
play itself out I mean unless you're
assuming that the evil capitalists are
just gonna take all of the flat-screen
televisions and put them in one big room
and not let anyone else have one the
logical assumption is that while you're
already on a road that's supposed to
produce the proper material productivity
and so well that's ten reasons as far as
I can tell that and so what I saw in
that that that the Communist Manifesto
is is like seriously flawed in virtually
every way it could possibly be flawed
and also all in an in an evidence that
Marx was the kind of narcissistic
thinker who could think he was he was
very intelligent person and so his
angles but what he thought what he
thought when he thought was that what he
thought was correct and he never went
the second stage which is wait a second
how could all of this go terribly wrong
and if you're a thinker especially a
sociological thinker especially a
thinker on the broad scale a social
scientist for example one of your moral
obligations is to think you know you
might be wrong about one of your
fundamental axioms or two or three or
ten and as a consequence you have the
moral obligation to walk through the
damn system and think well what if I'm
completely wrong here and things invert
and go exactly the wrong way like I
can't
I can't understand how anybody could
come up with an idea like the
dictatorship of the proletariat
especially after advocating its
implementation for with violent means
which is a direct part of the Communist
Manifesto and actually think if they
were thinking if they knew anything
about human beings and the proclivity
for malevolence that's part and parcel
of the individual human being that that
could do anything but lead to a special
form of Hell which is precisely what did
happen and so I'm going to close because
I have three minutes with with a bit of
evidence as well that Marx also thought
that what would happen inevitably as a
consequence of capitalism is that rich
would get richer and the poor would get
poorer so there would be an equality the
first thing I'd like to say is we do not
know how to set up a human system of
economics without inequality no one has
ever managed it including the Communists
and the form of inequality changed and
it's not obvious by any stretch of
imagination that the free market
economies of the West have more
inequality than the less free economies
in the rest of the world and the one
thing you can say about capitalism is
that although it produces inequality
which it absolutely does it also
produces wealth and all the other
systems don't they just produce
inequality
so here's here's a few stats here's a
few free market stats okay from 1800 to
2017 income growth adjusted for
inflation grew by 40 times but for
production workers in 16 times for
unskilled labor
well GDP fact GDP rose by a factor of
about 0.5 from 1 AD to 1800s so from 180
to 1800 ad it was like nothing flat and
then all of a sudden in the last two
hundred and seventeen years there's been
this unbelievably upward movement of
wealth and it doesn't only characterize
the tiny percentage of people at the top
who admittedly do have most of the
wealth the question is not only though
what's the inequality the question is
well what's happening to the absolutely
poor at the bottom and the answer that
is they're getting richer faster now
than they ever have in the history of
the world and we're eradicating poverty
in countries that have adopted moderate
free-market policies at a rate that's
unparalleled so here's an example the UN
Millennium of the UN Millennium Goals
was to reduce the the rate of absolute
poverty in the world by 50 percent
between 2000 and 2015 and they defined
that as a dollar ninety a day pretty low
you know but you have to start somewhere
um we beat we hit that at 2012 three
years ahead of schedule and you might be
cynical about that and say well it's
kind of an arbitrary number but the
curves are exactly the same at three
dollars and eighty three dollars and 80
cents a day and seven dollars and sixty
cents a day not as many people have hit
that but the rate of increase towards
that is the same the bloody UN thinks
that we'll be out of poverty defined by
a dollar ninety a day by the year 2030
it's unparalleled and so so the so the
rich may be getting richer but the poor
are getting richer too and that's that's
not the look I'll leave it at that
because I'm out of time but one of the
I'll leave it with this
the poor are not getting poor under
capitalism the poor are getting richer
under capitalism by a large margin and
I'll leave you with one statistic which
is that now in in Africa the child
mortality rate in Africa now is the same
as the child mortality rate was in
Europe in 1952 and so that's happened
within the span of one lifetime
and so if you're for the poor if you're
for the poor if you're actually
concerned that the poorest people in the
world rise above their starvation levels
then the all the evidence suggests that
the best way to do that is to implement
something approximating a free-market
economy and so thank you very much
and for the Fed I can see this yellow
okay thank you dr. Peterson dr. G Zack
thank you
okay first a brief introductory remark I
cannot but notice the irony of how
Peterson and I the participants in this
duel of the century are both
marginalized by the official academic
community I'm supposed to defend here
the left liberal line against
neoconservatives
really most of the attacks on me are now
precisely from left liberals just
remember the outcry against my critique
of lgbtq+ ideology and I'm sure that if
the leading figures in this field were
to be asked if I am fit to stand for
them they would turn in their grave even
if they are still alive so let me begin
by bringing together the three notions
from the title happiness communism
capitalism in one exemplary case China
today China in the last decade is
arguably the greatest economic success
story in human history hundreds of
millions raised from poverty into
middle-class existence
how did China achieve it the 20th
century left was defined by its
opposition to the two fundamental
tendencies of modernity the reign of
capital with its aggressive market
competition the authoritarian
bureaucratic state power today's China
combines these two features in its
extreme forum strong totalitarian state
state wild capitalist dynamics and it's
important to note they do it on behalf
of happiness of the majority of people
they don't mention communism to
legitimize the rule they prefer the old
convulsion notion of a harmonious
society but are the Chinese any happier
for all that although even the Dalai
Lama justifies Tibetan Buddhism in
western terms of the pursuit of
happiness and the avoidance of pain
happiness as a goal of our life is a
very problematic notion if we learned
anything from psychoanalysis it is that
we humans are very creative in
sabotaging our pursuit of happiness
happiness is a confused notion basically
it relies on the subjects inability or
unread enos to fully confront the
consequences of his/her their desire in
our daily lives we pretend to desire
things which we do not really desire so
that ultimately the worst thing that can
happen is for us to get what we
officially desire so I agree that human
life of freedom and dignity does not
consist just in searching for happiness
no matter how much we spiritualize it or
in the effort to actualize our inner
potentials we have to find some
meaningful cause beyond the mere
struggle for pleasurable survival
however I would like to add here a
couple of qualifications first since we
live in a modern era we cannot simply
refer to an unquestionable authority to
confer a mission or task on us
modernity means that yes we should carry
the burden but the main burden is
freedom itself we are responsible for
our burdens not only are we not allowed
cheap excuses for not doing our duty
duty itself should not serve as an
excuse we are never dressed instruments
of some higher cause once traditional
Authority loses its substantial power it
is not possible to return to it
all such returns are today a postmodern
fake does Donald Trump stand for
traditional values no his conservativism
is the postmodern performance a gigantic
ego trip in this sense of playing with
traditional values of
mixing references to them with open
obscenities is the ultimate
postmodern president in if we compare
with Bernie Sanders Trump is a
postmodern politician at its purest
while Sanders is rather an old-fashioned
moralist conservative thinkers claim
that the origin of our crisis is the
loss of our reliance on some transcended
divinity or higher value if we are left
to ourselves
if everything is historically
conditioned and relative then there is
nothing preventing us to indulge in our
lowest tendencies but is this really the
lesson to be learned from mob killing
looting and burning on behalf of
religion it is often claimed that true
or not religion makes some otherwise bad
people do good things from today's
experience I think we should rather
stick to Steve Weinberg's claim that
while without religion good people would
have been doing good things and bad
people bad things only something like
religion can make good people do bad
things more than a century ago in his
brothers karamazov Dostoyevsky warned
against the dangers of godless godless
moral nihilism if God doesn't exist then
everything is permitted the French
philosopher and reg Richmond applied
Dostoyevsky's critique of godless
nihilism to September 11 and the title
of his book dr. Erskine Manhattan
suggests as the title suggests he
couldn't have been more wrong the lesson
of today's terrorism is that if there is
a God then everything even blowing up
hundreds of innocent bystanders is
permitted to those who claim to act
directly on behalf of God the same goals
also for godless Stalinist communists
they are the ultimate proof of it
every
was permitted to them since they
perceived themselves as direct
instrument of their divinity of the
historical necessity of progress towards
communism that's the big problem of
ideologies how to make good decent
people do horrible things second yes we
should carry our burden except the
suffering that goes with it but a danger
lurks here that of a subtle reversal
don't fall in love that my position with
your suffering
never presumed that your suffering is in
itself a proof of your authenticity
renunciation of pleasure can easily turn
into pleasure of renunciation itself for
example an example not from your
Conservatives white left liberals love
to denigrate their own culture and blame
Eurocentrism for our evils but it is
instantly clear how this self
denigration brings a profit of its own
through this renouncing of their
particular roots multicultural liberals
reserved for themselves the universal
position graciously soliciting others to
assert their particular identity white
multiculturalist liberals embodied the
lie of identity politics next point
Jacques Lacan wrote something
paradoxical but deeply true that even is
what a jealous husband claims about his
about his wife that she sleeps with
other men is all true his relative is
nonetheless pathological the pallid
pathological element is the husband's
need for jealousy it's the only way for
him to sustain his identity along the
same lines one could say that even if
most of the Nazi claims about Bruce they
exploit Germans they seduce German girls
and so on were true which they were not
of
their anti-semitism would still be a
pathological phenomenon because it
ignored the true reason why the Nazis
needed anti-semitism in the night
revision their society is an organic
whole of harmonious collaboration so an
external intruder is needed to account
for divisions and antagonisms the same
hold for how today in Europe at least
the anti-immigrant populist deal with
the refugees the cause of problems which
are I claim imminent to today's global
capitalism is projected onto an external
intruder again even if the reported
incident with the refugees there are
great problems I admit it
even all these reports are true the
published story about them is a lie with
anti-semitism we are approaching the
topic of telling stories
Hitler was one of the greatest
storytellers of the 20th century in the
1920s many Germans experienced their
situation as a confused mess they didn't
understand what is happening to them
with military defeat economic crisis
what they perceived as moral decay and
so on
Hitler provided a story a plot which was
precisely that of a Jewish plot we are
in this mess because of the Druze that's
what I would like to insist on we are
telling ourselves stories about
ourselves in order to acquire a
meaningful experience of our lives
however this is not enough one of the
most stupid wisdoms and they're mostly
stupid is an enemy is someone whose
story you have not heard really they is
are you also ready to affirm that Hitler
was our enemy because his story was not
hurt the experience that we have of our
lives from within the story we tell
ourselves about ourselves in
order to account for what we are doing
is and this is what I call ideology
fundamentally a lie the truth lies
outside in what we do in a similar way
the alt-right obsession with cultural
Marxism expresses the rejection to
confront the fact that the phenomena
they criticize is the effect of the
cultural Marxist plot moral degradation
sexual promiscuity consumerist feminism
and so on are the outcome of the
imminent dynamic of capitalist societies
I would like to refer to a classic
Daniel Bell cultural contradictions of
capitalism written back in 1976 where
the author argues that the unbounded
drive of modern capitalism undermines
the moral foundations of the original
Protestant ethic and in the new
afterword well offers a bracing
perspective on contemporary Western
societies revealing the crucial cultural
fault lines we face as the 21st century
is here the turn twerks culture is a key
component of capitalist reproduction and
concomitant to it the commodification of
cultural life itself
I think crucial moments of capitalists
expanded reproduction so the term
cultural Marxism I think plays the same
role as death of the Jewish plot in
anti-semitism it projects or transposed
some eminent antagonism however you call
it ambiguity tension of our social
economic life onto an external course in
exactly the same way now let me tell you
a different give you a different more
problematic example in exactly the same
way liberal critics of Trump and
outright never seriously asked how our
liberal society
give birth to Trump in this sense the
image of Donald Trump is also a fetish
the last think liberal sees before
confronting actual social tensions
Hegel's motto evil resides in the gaze
which is evil everywhere fully applies
here the very liberal gaze which
dominates Trump is also evil because it
ignores how its own failures open up the
space for Trump's type of patriotic
populism next point one should stop
blaming hedonist egotism for our wolves
the true opposite of negative self-love
is not altruism a concern for the common
good but Envy resentment which makes me
act against my own interests this is why
as many perspicuous philosophers clearly
saw evil is profoundly spiritual in some
sense more spiritual than goodness this
is why egalitarianism itself should
never be accepted at its face value it
can well secretly invert the standard
pronunciation accomplished to benefit
others egalitarianism often de facto
means I am ready to renounce something
so that others will also not have it
this is I think now comes the
problematic part for some of you maybe
the problem with political correctness
what appears as its excesses its
regulatory zeal is I think an important
reaction to that masks the reality of a
defeat my hero is here a black lady
tirana Burke who created the mid-to
campaign more than a decade ago she
observed in a recent critical note death
in the years since the movement began it
deployed an unwavering obsession with
the perpetrators me too is all too often
a genuine protest filtered through
resentment
should we then drop egalitarianism no
equality can also mean and that's the
quality I advocate creating the space
for as many as possible individuals to
develop their different potentials it is
that my paradoxical claim it is today's
capitalism that equalizes us to mark and
causes the loss of many talents so what
about the balance between equality and
hierarchy did we really move too much in
the direction of equality is there in
today's United States really too much
equality I think a simple overview of
the situation point in the opposite
direction
far from pushing us too far the left is
gradually losing its ground already for
decades its trademarks universal health
care free education and so on are
continuously diminished look at Bernie
Sanders and I don't idealize him program
it is just a version of what half a
century ago in Europe was simply the
predominant social democracy and it's
today decried as a threat to our
freedoms to the American Way of life and
shown and so on I see no threat in to
free creativity in this program on the
contrary I see health care and education
and so on as enabling me to focus my
life on more important creative issues I
see equality this basic equality of
trench's as a space for creating
differences and yes why not
even different more appropriate here are
his furthermore I find it very hard to
ground
today's inequalities as they are
documented for example by Piketty in his
book on to ground today's inequalities
in different competencies competencies
for what in totalitarian states
competencies are determined politically
but market success is also not innocent
and neutral as a regulator of the social
recognition of competences let me know
briefly deal with a in a friendly way I
claim with what became known sorry for
the irony as the lobster topic I'm far
from a simple social constructionism
here I deeply appreciate evolutionary
thought of course we are also natural
beings and our DNA as we all know
overlaps I may be wrong around 99
percent with that of some monkeys this
means something
but nature I think we should never
forget this is not a stable hierarchical
system but full of improvisations it
develops like French cuisine a French
guy gave me this idea that French the
origin of many famous French dishes or
drinks is that when they wanted to
produce a standard piece of food or
drink something went wrong but then they
realized that this failure can be
resolved as success they were making
cheese in the usual way but the trees
got rotten and infected smelling bad and
they said oh my God look we have our own
original french fries or they were
making wine in the usual way then
something went wrong with fermentation
and so they began to produce champagne
and so on and so on I'm not making just
a joke here because I think that it is
exactly like this that and that's the
lessons of psychoanalysis that our
sexuality works sexual instincts are of
course biologically determined but look
what we humans made out of them they are
not limited to the mating season they
can develop in a permanent up into a
permanent obsession sustained by
obstacles that demand to be overcome in
short into appropriately metaphysical
passion that perturbs the biological
rhythm with twists like endlessly
prolonging satisfaction in courtly love
engaging in different perversions and so
on and so on so it's still yes
biologically conditioned sexuality but
it is if I may use this term trans
functionalized it becomes a moment of a
different cultural however you call it
logic and they claim the same goes for
tradition TS Eliot the great
conservative
wrote quote what happens when a new work
of art is created is something that
happens simultaneously to all the work
of art which preceded it the past should
be altered by the present as much as the
present is directed by the past end of
quote
what does this mean let me mention the
change enacted by Christianity it's not
just that in spite of all our natural
and cultural differences the same divine
spark dwells in everyone but this divine
spark enables us to create what
Christians call holy ghost or holy
spirit the community which here are six
family values are at some level at least
abolished remember Paul's works from
Galatians there is no longer true or
Greek there is no longer male and female
in Christ a democracy extend this logic
to the political space in spite of all
differences in competence the ultimate
decision should stay with all of us the
wager of democracy is that we should not
give all power to competent experts it
was precisely communist in power who
legitimized the rule by posing as fake
experts and incidentally I'm far from
believing in ordinary people's wisdom we
often need a master figure to push us
out of an inertia and I'm not afraid to
say that forces us to be free freedom
and responsibility helped they require
an effort in the highest function of an
authentic master is to literally to
awaken us to our freedom we are not
spontaneously really free furthermore
think - I think that social power and
authority cannot be directly grounded in
competence in our human universe power
in the sense of exerting Authority is
something much more mysterious even
irrational Kierkegaard my and
everybody's favorite geologist wrote if
a child says he will obey his father
because his father is a competent and
good guy this is an affront to father's
Authority and he applied the same logic
to Christ himself Christ was justified
by the fact of being God son not by his
competency or capacities as Kierkegaard
put it every good student of theology
can put things better than Christ this
there is no such authority in nature
lobster's may have here he undoubtedly
but the main guy among them I don't
think he has authority in this sense
again the wager of democracy is dead and
that's the subtle thing not against
competence and so on but that political
power and competence or expertise should
be kept apart in Stalinism precisely
they were not kept apart while already
in ancient Greece they knew that they
have to be kept apart which is why
they're popular weight was even combined
with lottery often so where does
communism just to conclude where does
communism enter here why do I still
cling to this cursed name when I know
and fully admit the 20th century
communist project in all its failure how
it felt giving birth to new forms of
murderous terror capitalism won but
today and that's my claim we can debate
about it the question is does today's
global capitalism
contain strong enough antagonisms which
prevent its indefinite reproduction I
think there are such antagonisms the
threat of the ecological catastrophe the
consequence of new technical
developments especially invited genetics
and new forms of apartheid all these
antagonisms concerned what Marx called
Commons the shared substance of our
social being first of course the Commons
of external nature threatened by
pollution global warming and so on now
let me be precise here I'm well aware of
how uncertain analysis and projections
are in this domain it will be certain
only when it will be too late and I am
well aware of the temptation to engage
in precipitous extrapolations when I was
younger to give you a critical example
there was in Germany an obsession with
valve turbine the dyeing of forests with
predictions that in a couple of decades
Europe will be without forests but
according to recent estimates there are
now more forest areas in Europe than 100
years or 50 years ago but there is
nonetheless I claim the prospect of a
catastrophe here scientific data seemed
to me at least abundant enough and we
should act in a large-scale collective
way and I also think this may be
critical to some of you there is a
problem with capitalism here for the
simple reason that its managers not
because of their evil nature but that's
the logic of capitalism care to explain
self reproduction and environmental
consequences are simply not part of the
game this is again not a moral reproach
in incidentally so that you will not
think that I don't know what I'm talking
about
in communist countries those in power
were obsessed with expanded reproduction
and were not under public control so the
situation was even
verse so how to act first by admitting
we are in a deep mess there is no simple
democratic solution here the idea that
people themselves should decide what to
do about the ecology sounds deep but it
begs an important question even with
their comprehension is not distorted by
corporate interests what qualifies them
to pass a judgement in such a delicate
matter plus the radical measures
advocated by some ecologists can
themselves trigger new catastrophes let
me mention Russ the idea which is
floating around of solar radiation
management the continuous massive
dispersal of aerosols into our
atmosphere to reflect and absorb
sunlight and thus cool the planet can be
even imagine how the fragile balance of
our earth function and in what
unpredictable ways geoengineering can
disturb it in such times of arrogantly
when we know we have to act but don't
know how to act thinking is needed maybe
we should turn around a little bit
Marx is famous thesis 11 in that in our
new century we should say that maybe in
the last century we tried all too fast
to change the world the time has come to
step back and interpret it the second
threat the Commons of internal nature
with new biogenetic technologists the
creation of a new man in the literal
sense of changing human nature becomes a
realist prospect
I mean primarily so-called popularly
neural link the direct link between our
brain and digital machines and then
brains among themselves this I think is
the true game changer the digitalization
of our brain opens up unheard of new
possibilities of control directly
sharing your experience with your
beloved may appear attractive but what
about sharing them with an agency
without you even knowing it finally the
common space of humanity itself we live
in one in the same world which is more
and more interconnected but nonetheless
deeply divided so how to react to this
the first and sadly predominant reaction
is the one of protective self enclosure
the world out there is in a mess let's
protect ourselves by all kinds of walls
it seems that our countries are run
relatively well that is the mess the
so-called roads countries find
themselves in not connected to how we
interact with them take what is perhaps
the ultimate rogue state Congo warlord
cruel provinces there are always dealing
with Western companies selling them
minerals where would our computers be
without Colton from Congo and what about
foreign interventions in Iraq and Syria
or by our proxies like Saudi Arabia in
Yemen here refugees are created a new
world order is emerging a world of can I
just finish the page two minutes
literally a world of peaceful
coexistence of civilizations but in what
way does attraction
forced marriages and homophobic
homophobia are okay just their limited
limited to another country which is
otherwise fully included into the world
market this is how refugees again are
created the second reaction is global
capitalism with a human face think about
socially responsible corporate figures
like Bill Gates or George Soros they
passionately support LGBT they advocate
charities and so on but even in its
extreme forum opening up our borders to
the refugees treating them like one of
us they only provide what is medicine
what in medicine is called a symptomatic
treatment
the solution is not for the rich Western
countries to receive all immigrants but
somehow to try to change the situation
which creates massive waves of
immigration and we are complicit in this
if such a change a utopia know the true
utopia is that we can survive without
such a change so here I think I know
it's provocative to call this a plea for
communism I do it a little bit to
provoke things but what is needed is
none delayed in all these spheres
I claim ecology digital control unity of
the world capitalist market which does
great things I admit it
has to be somehow limited regulated and
so on before you say it's a utopia I
will tell you but just think about in
what way global market already functions
today I always thought that
neoliberalism is a fake term if you look
closely you will see that state place
today
more important role than ever precisely
in the richest capitalist economies so
you know the market is already limited
but not in the right way to put it
naively so a pessimist conclusion what
will happen in spite of protests here
and there we will probably continue to
slide to work some kind of apocalypse
awaiting large catastrophes to awaken us
so I don't accept any cheap optimism
when somebody tries to convince me that
in spite of all the problems there is a
light at the end of the tunnel my
instant reply is yes and it's probably
another train coming to Warsaw
thank you very much
please don't do this because I really
think that that's why I I hope you
Jordan aggravated that why we are here
engaged in this debate don't take it as
a cheap competition it may be death but
we are as you said in your introduction
desperately trying to confront serious
problems I mean for example when I
mentioned China China
I didn't mean to celebrate it that
worries me terribly my god is this our
future yeah sorry
sorry for this story please the discount
take away this from my ten minutes that
repeaters in ten minutes to you to reply
so I like to speak extemporaneously but
dr. Z Jaques discussion was so complex
that there's no way that I can juggle my
responses spontaneously so okay yeah
achievement managed I would say so
so I heard much of I heard much of what
I heard I agreed with but we can get to
that I'm gonna respond with a knife all
right well I died I heard a criticism of
capitalism but no real support of
Marxism and and that's an interesting
thing because for me the the terms of
the argument were well there were three
terms of the argument let's say there
was capitalism there was Marxism and
there was happiness and I would say dr.
Dziedzic focused probably more on the
problems of capitalism and the problems
of happiness than on the utility of
Marxism and that actually comes as a
surprise to me because I presumed that
much of what I would hear would be a
support of something approximating
traditional or even a traditional
Marxism which is why I organized the
first part of my talk as an attack
against Marxism per se ok so now she
joins out that there are problems of
capitalism and I would like to say that
I'm perfectly aware that there are
problems with capitalism I wasn't
defending capitalism actually in some
sense I was defending it in comparison
to communism which is not the same thing
because as Winston Churchill said about
democracy you know it's the worst form
of government there is except for all
the other forms and so you might say the
same thing about capitalism is that it's
the worst form of economic arrangement
you could possibly manage except for
every other one that we've ever tried
and and then and I'm dead serious about
that I'm not trying to be flippant I
mean that it isn't obvious to me and
when dr. Jacque is speaking in more
apocalyptic terms it isn't obvious to me
that we can solve the problems that
confront us you know and it it's not
also not a message that I have been
purveying that unbridled capitalism per
se as an isolated
what would you say social economic
structure actually constitutes the
proper answer to the problems that
confront us so I haven't made that case
in any of the lectures that I've
anything I've written or any of the
lectures that I've done because I don't
believe it to be true
he said well what's the problems with
capitalism
well the commodification of cultural
life all life fair enough
there's something that isn't exactly
right about reducing everything to
economic competition and capitalism
certainly pushes in that direction
advertising culture pushes in that
direction sales and marketing culture
pushes in that direction and there's
reasons for that and I have a certain
amount of admiration for the necessity
of advertisers and salesmen and
marketers but that doesn't mean that the
transformation of all elements of life
into element into commodities in a
capitalist sense is the best way forward
I don't think it is the best way forward
I think the evidence for that's actually
quite clear there is by the way a
relationship this is something I didn't
point out before there is a relationship
between wealth and happiness it's quite
well defined in the psychological
literature now it's not exactly obvious
whether the happiness measures are
measures of happiness or whether they're
measures of the absence of misery and my
sense is as a psychometrician who's
looked at these scales that people are
more concerned with not being miserable
than they are with being happy those are
all actually separate emotional states
mediated by different psycho biological
systems it's a technical point but it's
important one the there is a
relationship between absolute level of
income and self-reported lack of misery
or happiness and it's pretty linear
until you hit I would say something
approximating decent working-class
income and so what seems to happen is
that wealth makes you happy as long as
it keeps the bill collectors at bay like
once you've got to the point where the
misery is staved off as much as it can
be by the fact that you're not
absolutely in you're not in absolutely
economically dire straits then adding
more money to your life has no
relationship what's
so ever to your well-being and so it's
clear that past a certain minimal point
additional material provision is not
sufficient to let's say redeem us
individually or socially and it's
certainly the case that the radical
wealth production that characterizes
capitalism might produce a fatal threat
to the structure of our social systems
and our broader ecosystems who knows I'm
not absolutely convinced of that for a
variety of reasons I mean jejak pointed
out for example that there are more
forests and Europe in now than there
were a hundred years ago there's
actually more forests in the entire
northern hemisphere than there were a
hundred years ago and the news on the
ecological front is not as dismal as the
people who put out the most dismal news
would have you think and there is some
possibility that doesn't mean that there
aren't elements of it that are dismal
you know what we've done to the oceans
is definitely something catastrophic and
we definitely have our problems but it
is possible that human ingenuity might
solve that what else there are
inequalities generated by capitalism a
proclivity towards a shallow materialism
the probability of corruption the thing
about that for me is those are
catastrophes that are part of the
struggle for human existence itself and
not something to be laid at the feet of
any given social political system
especially one that seems to be
producing a fair Markum of wealth for
the poorest section of the population
and raising people up to the point where
you know their lives aren't unending an
unending day-to-day struggle for mere
survival there's some evidence for
example that if you can get GDP up to
about five thousand dollars per person
per year
well that's GDP that people start to
become concerned about environmental
degradation and start to take actions to
prevent it and so there is some
possibility that if we're lucky we can
get the bottom billion or two billion
people in the world or three billion as
the population grows up to the point
where they're wealthy enough so they
actually start to care enough about the
environment so that we could act
collectively to solve environmental
problems now you might say well by that
time we'll be out of earth
you know we'll have we'll have exhausted
the resources that are in front of us so
desperately that there's no hope of that
but I would like to remind you of a
famous bet between Julian Simon and the
biologist ed at Stanford who wrote Paul
Ehrlich who wrote the Population Bomb
they bet air like who thought we were
gonna be overpopulated by the year 2000
bet Simon that by the year 2000
commodity prices would have increased
dramatically as a consequence of
evidence that we were running out of
material resources they made a famous
bet over a 25 year period and err like
paid off Simon in the year 2000 because
commodity prices went down and not up
and so there is no solid evidence that
the fact that our population is growing
and will peak out by the way at about 9
billion there's no solid indication that
the consequence of that is that we are
in fact running out of necessary
material resources and so it's a danger
but it just it's not a danger that's
proven and there is some utility and
considering that the addition of several
billion more brains to the planet
especially if they were well nourished
brains as they increasingly are might
help us generate enough problem-solvers
so that we can stay ahead of the looming
ecological catastrophe as our population
balloons outwards now we're going to
peak at 9 billion it's not much higher
than we are now and it looks like we
might be able to manage it yeah the
other thing is that I didn't hear an
alternative really from dr. Jack you
know he admitted that the rise to
success of the Chinese was in part a
consequence of the of the allowance of
market forces and decried the
authoritarian tendencies and fair enough
that's exactly yet it also seemed to me
that the social justice group identity
processes that dr. Dusek was decrying
are to me a logical derivation from the
oppression narrative that's a
fundamental presupposition of Marxism so
there I never heard a defense of Marxism
in that part of his argument as well and
so for me again it's to ask what's the
alternative
I also heard an argument for
egalitarianism and but I heard it
defined as equality of opportunity not
as equality of outcome which I see as a
clearly defined Marxist aim I heard an
argument for a modified social
distribution of wealth but that's
already part and parcel of most modern
free-market states with a wide variation
and an appropriate variation of
government intervention all of which
constitute their own experiment we don't
know how much social intervention is
necessary to flatten the tendency of
hierarchies to become tilted so terribly
that only the people at the top have
everything and all of the people at the
bottom have nothing it's a very
difficult battle to fight against that
profound tendency much deeper than the
tendency of capitalism itself and we
don't exactly know what to do about it
so we run experiments and that seems to
be working perfectly reasonably as far
as I can tell that's see well I'll close
with this capitalism in the free market
well that's the worst form of social
organization possible as I said except
for all the others there is a positive
relationship between economics measured
by income and happiness or psychological
well-being which might be the absence of
misery I certainly do not believe and
the evidence does not suggest that
material security is sufficient
I do believe however that insofar as
there is a relationship between
happiness and material security that the
free market system has demonstrated
itself as the most efficient manner to
achieve that and that was actually the
terms of the argument so that's if it's
capitalism versus Marxism with regards
to human happiness it's still the case
that the free market constitutes the
clear winner and maybe capitalism will
not solve our problems I actually don't
believe that it will I've in fact argued
that the proper pathway forward is one
of individual moral responsibility aimed
at the highest good and something for me
that's rooted in our underlying
judeo-christian tradition that insists
that each person is a what is sovereign
in their own right and a locus of
ultimate value which is something that
you can accept regardless of your
religious presuppositions and something
that you do accept if you participate in
a society such as ours even the fact
that you vote that you're charged
without responsibility is an indication
that our society is structured such that
we presume that each person is a locus
of responsibility and decision making of
such import that the very stability of
the state
depends upon the integrity of their
psyche the intent the integrity of their
character and so what I've been
suggesting to people is that they adopt
as much responsibility as they possibly
can in keeping with that in keeping with
their aim at the highest possible good
which to me is something approximating a
balance between what's good for you as
an individual and what's good for your
family in keeping with what's good for
you as an individual and then what's
good for society in the larger frame
such that it's also good for you and
your family and that's a form of an well
an elaborated iterated game a form of
elaborated cooperation it's a
sophisticated way of looking at the ways
society could possibly be organized and
I happen to believe that that has to
happen at the individual level first and
that's the pathway forward that I see
and so that's my 10 minute comment
I go up
Thank You dr. Peterson doctor spent a
little bit of my time I will try to be
as short as possible so a couple of
remarks and then my final point why I
think this self limitation of capitalism
is needed first about happiness just a
couple of remarks John I want to ask you
but isn't it I am I dreaming
I think I'm not I remember a couple of
years ago it was reported all around the
world some kind of investigation
percentage of people interviewed in
different countries do they feel happy
with their life and the shock was that
some Scandinavian countries which will
which we considered social democratic
paradise were very low while Bangladesh
I think was close to the top now I know
this logic has a limit I don't buy the
of poor people are happy in
their world there and so on but you know
my argument here is not against you my
argument here is problematizing
happiness even more look this may
interest you I was years ago in in I
think Lithuania and we debated report on
this in one of my books when were people
in some perverted sense and this is the
critic of the category of happiness for
me happy and we came to the crazy result
after the Soviet intervention
Czechoslovakia in 1970s and 80s
why for happiness first you don't have
you should not have too much democracy
because this brings the burden of
responsibility happiness means there is
another guy out there you can put all
the blame on him and as the joke went in
Czechoslovakia if there is bad weather a
storm or this communist screwed it up
again that's one condition of happiness
the other condition much more subtle one
is and this was done in Czechoslovakia
did those dark times after so the life
was relatively moderately
but not perfect like there was meat all
the time maybe once a month there was
not meat in the stores it was very good
to remind you how happy you are the
other time another thing they had a
paradise which should be at the proper
distance West Germany affluence it was
not too far but not directly accessible
you know so I asked it was so maybe in
your critique of communist regimes I
agree with you you should more focus on
something that I experienced of you know
don't look only at the tear or
ultimately totalitarian regime there was
a kind of a silent perverted pact
between at least in this late a little
bit more tolerant but I still oppose
them communist regimes between power and
population the message was leave us the
power don't mess it worse and we
guarantee you a relatively safe life
employment private pleasures private
niche and so on and so on so I am NOT
surprised but again this is not for me
the argument for the Congress but
against happiness that you know people
said when coming when the walls fell
down what a wonder in Poland my god in
in in like Salah darkness which was
prohibited hiragana of triumph at the
elections who could imagine this
yes but the true miracle in a bad sense
for me was four years later
democratically ex-communist came back to
power so you know don't again this is
for me not the argument for them but
simply for the let's call it corrupted
nature of happiness so my formula maybe
you'd agree with it is my basic Dogma is
happiness should be treated as a
necessary byproduct if you focus on it
you are lost it comes as a byproduct of
you working for a cause and so on that's
the basic thing for me
second point maybe we disagree here
China of course the miracle economic
miracle was due to unlink market refer
and so on but and here comes my
pessimism some of my liberal friends are
telling me
imagine what would they have achieved
with also political democratization I'm
a pessimist here no they found a perfect
formula of how and that is the paradox
of China today the Communist Party is
the best manager of capitalism and
protector against workers the truly
dangerous thing in China today is not to
flirt with Western ideas is to organize
trade union stood you know like this is
what worries me this perfect combination
between unleashing capitalism and still
the authoritarian rule or to put it in
another way my worry is dead today all
around the world this eternal marriage
between capitalism and democracy is
slowly disappearing till now I admit it
capitalism needed from time to time from
1020 years of dictatorship when things
started to improve democracy returns
kill South Korea and so on I wonder if
we are still at debt now it's just very
quickly your basic point in the
introduction in your introduction you
know I almost am tempted to say the way
you present that communist manifesto the
simplified image and so on come on it's
crazy to say but on many points I I
agree with you and it's a very complex
argument Marx didn't have for example a
good theory of how social power exists
his idea was simply with disappearance
of class structure it secretly although
he wouldn't have accepted it a
technocratic dream like by expert social
life will be run as a perfect machine
although he was it
aware of the problem which is why he was
so enthusiastic marks about Paris
Commune you know which was precisely not
centralized power so I'm not just
defending marks I'm saying it was not
clear to him and so let's drop that
maybe I have more interesting things to
say ah another point nonetheless where
well at one point I'm ready to take
where did you find this discourse maybe
for today's politically correct drugs
and so on that this egalitarianism there
is one passage in his late critic of
Goethe program where Marx directly
accesses the problem of equality and he
dismisses it as a strict bourgeois
category explicitly explicitly for him
communism is not egalitarianism it's yes
here are his but not based on capitalism
okay I'm not the Fed totally defending
here Marx I'm just saying don't Republic
to March okay but to conclude because
yes I want to keep my promise to be a
little bit shorter you know I agree with
you on many points but you know what my
problem with my problem that I was
aiming at with all the openings I know
we don't know really what is happening
with ecology and so on okay let's take
options you mentioned them but isn't it
for me correct me if I'm wrong and I
don't mean this rhetorically maybe I'm
really wrong but the problem of oceans
can the only way for me is some kind of
cooperated international action and so
on you cannot simply leave it to the
market that's what I'm saying
this is the fateful limit that I see
about this diminishing poverty and so on
I am aware of it I tend to agree with I
but at the same time so many explosive
tangents for example do you know about
South Africa it's a terrifying situation
on the edge of the civil war to be very
brutal the only thing that simplified it
that really happened with end of
apartheid is that the old ruling class
is simplified in growth a smart system
was joined by a new black ruling class
which is not doing a good job so they
are trying to play the race card it's
still the consequence of white
colonialism and so on and so on but but
tendrils are terrifying and here I was
pleading for not abolishing borders and
so on but this type of I don't know how
to put it global trend cooperation like
again the example of Congo that I
mentioned or like forget the killing of
that guy Khashoggi it's horrible but the
true nightmare is Yemen today but I mean
you said somewhere that we should well
think without engaging in large-scale
reform what the consequences will be if
you okay very briefly I agree with you
that the gap of standard Marxism was
that the proletarian revolution will be
a place where you do something and you
know exactly what you do if there is a
lesson of the 20th century is that this
tragic logic you want something may be
good the result is catastrophic holds
absolutely also for revolution and so on
and so on
but but like in spite of all this and I
don't know what forum will escape I'm
not pleading for a new land in its party
or whatever and leading for new forums
of international cooperation and so on I
agree with you when you said the
majority of us is not even really aware
of the seriousness of especially the
poor of ecological problems and so on
and I think would you agree that the
situation is here much more subtle and
theme we it's that logic that in track
analysis is called the survival Carlo
ignant in French rooster bein recipe mmm
we know ecological problems but we don't
really take them seriously and here I
see problems and I don't see an easy way
out I I am a pessimist if you ask me
when people say no but they're growing
protests are growing and so on and so on
yes I'm listening to this story from
when I was young you know we are growing
and then look what happened the mega
tragedy is for me for example what
happened to syriza they were elected for
change whatever and they become and I'm
not blaming them they become the perfect
executor of of austerity program so I
just see problems I'm a pessimist and
I'm not a radical pessimist but you have
to maybe here we are different I noticed
with your final speech that final moment
of your investment that it's very
strained because usually Marxists have
this stupid optimist entrepreneurial
just get rid of capitalist terror and we
will all be happy my god a much more a
pessimist
I don't believe in human goodness I will
never underestimate evil never asked
underestimate Envy I mean it's part of
my nature in Slovenia we have a
wonderful story godlike figure comes to
a farmer and I will stop immediately and
ask and ask him I will do to you to you
whatever you want just I warn you I will
do twice the same to your neighbor you
know what's living farmer answer time
take one of my eyes you know we are
indeed don't underestimate this I don't
see any simple clear way out thank you
thank you both very much it's pretty
clear I think to all of us that you both
have quite a bit to say to each other
and so and so I think before we we jump
to some audience questions I thought it
would be nice to give each of you a
chance to ask a response or ask a
question or two from each other so
starting with you dr. Peterson maybe you
want simply to counter-attack it wasn't
fair well I've only to do your reply I
had three questions and queue of them
are now completely irrelevant and so I
have one left I guess and I'm not sure
that it's a fair question but maybe it's
it seems to me to be a fair question
your your estranged Marxist to have a
discussion with and well but here's why
that this is not an insult by any
stretch of the imagination I mean one of
the things that struck me when I was
looking at your work was that your well
first of all you're a character you know
and that's a that's that's an
interesting thing like you're decent not
anything it's a sign of it's a sign of
originality and and it's a sign of a
certain amount of moral courage and and
and it's a sign of a certain temperament
and it makes you humorous and
charismatic and attractive and and and
and I think you appeal to young people
the way that outside intellectual rebels
appeal to young people and so those are
all positive things that can be used
positively or negatively and my question
is like it seems to me that your your
your reputation unless I'm very
misinformed about this is as a strong
supporter of Marxist doctrines on the
left or was that and so then my question
is given the originality of your thought
why'd why is it that you came to presume
at some point in your life perhaps no
now and perhaps still that the promotion
of Marxism rather say rather than as
eASIC ISM was appropriate because it
seems to me that there's enough
originality in your body of thought and
lateral thinking in the manner in which
you approach intellectual ideas that
there's just no reason for you to be
allied with a doctrine that's a hundred
and seventy years old and that is if
capitalism is rife with problems is
twice as ripe as problem with problems
as that and so you're kind of a mystery
to me in that way and so that's my
question
okay very briefly I I developed
systematically in my book critical
insights into many traditional Marxist
resist so no doubt here you know what I
still admire nonetheless in Marx not
those simplicity's of communist
manifesto but I still think that his
so-called critique of political economy
capital and so on is a tremendous
achievement as a description of the
dynamics of capitalist society and if
you read it closely
Marx is much more ambiguous and open
there for example he mentions for
example app report what you refer to he
mentions that law of diminishing return
like well why crisis will arrive
necessarily poor are getting poorer but
in his honest enough to enumerate seven
or eight counter tendencies and if you
read him closely you will see that
precisely those tendencies prevailed
later or forget Communist Manifesto go
to read his political analysis of it
unsurpassable 18 Brumaire and so on of
the 1848 revolution which are incredibly
complex no traces or traces of that
class binary day there Marx deals with
middle classes with crucial loom
proletariat with the ambiguous role of
intellectuals and so on and so on but
basically what I was pleading for and I
like to put it in paradoxical turn was
for a return of from Marx back to Hegel
I define myself more as a girl yet why
Hegel is consider Cagle is considered a
madman you know the guy absolute knowing
and so on and so on no eggless much more
modest and open the danger in Marxism is
for me this teleological structure we
are at the zero point but there is a
unique chance of a reversal into a new
emancipated society and so on and the
danger here is that of self
instrumentalization
Praetorian Communist Party is a an agent
of history which knows the laws of
history to put it follows them and so on
that the catastrophe in Hegel such a
position is strictly prohibited in Hegel
whenever you act you earth so you know
you have to there is no position of this
pure acting where you know what you are
doing
and the result with it will be so I this
this would be this would be my main
point so yes my my my formula is kind of
ironically I know Hegel is the greatest
idealist materialist reversal of Marx by
turning back to haggle for Hegel Hegel
says in a part that people don't read
introduction to forward sorry to
philosophy of right
he says explicitly that the owner of
Minerva takes off in the evening when
there is dusk so philosophy can grass
grasp a social order when it's already
in its decay philosophy cannot see into
the future its radical openness we need
this openness today the tragedy today
may be we agree here is that we really
don't have
a basic house they call it cognitive
mapping I don't think we have here a
clear insight into where we stand where
we are moving and so on and so on so I'm
much more again sincerely of a pessimist
can I ask you now so well I don't have
any thing to quibble about with what you
just said but well no there's not even a
but really it's that the even if the if
what you said about Marx's more
sophisticated thought is true I think
the unfortunate reality is that any
support for Marxism especially directed
towards those are who are young is
likely to be read as support for the
most radical and revolutionary
proclivities and I would say that as
they're outlined in in the document that
I described in the communist manifesto
that they're of extraordinary danger and
so it seems to me that by attempting to
you know rescue the sheep yuvan you've
sort of invited the dragon into the
house and that seems to me to be
dangerous and unfortunately asking you
mine question because you know very
naively you mention first do you really
where did you find the data that I
complete don't see it okay let me begin
by this you designate you're under
quotation mark I'm not characterizing
here enemy or what you are fighting
against F sometimes you call it
postmodern neo Marxism I know what you
mean all this from political correctness
this excesses of whatever spirit of envy
and so on and
the one do you think they are really
where did you find it that I don't know
them I would ask you here give me some
names or whatever one of the Marxists
here I don't know any I don't who who is
the Marxist here show me any big names
of political correctness I think they
they steer like a good vampire fear
garlic and this is why they are already
the one who is not a marquis but it
leaves approaches economic topic Bernie
Sanders he is already under attack as
white male and all that stuff and so on
I simply I simply my problem would be
with this one what you described as
postmodern neo Marxism where is really
the Marxist element in it therefore
equality sorry we're there for equality
at this cultural struggles proper names
how do we call it rather do you see in
them in political correctness and so on
any genuine wheel of to change society I
don't see I think it's a hyper
moralization hyper moralization which is
a silent admission of a defeat that's my
problem why do you call give me it again
it's not a rhetorical question for
politely saying you are an idiot you
don't know what you are talking about
it's simply I would like to know because
you and I like this often when you
attack somebody you said aggressively
and what truth
read more tell me whom so I'm asking you
now not read more I don't advise you but
who are give me some names and so on and
who are this post-modern egalitarian
neo-marxist and where do you see any
kind even of a Marxism I see in it
mostly and and impotent and utterly
impotent moralization please I'm so
sorry the devil well I mean organization
like Jonathan heights
what's it called
heterodox Academy and other
organizations like that have documented
an absolute dearth of conservative
voices in the social sciences and the
humanities and about 25% according to
the what I think are reliable surveys
approximately 25% of social scientists
in the u.s. identified themselves as
Marxists and so there's that well okay
but but let alone anyone I know a couple
of Marxist for example that's very solid
economic work I don't totally David
Harvey one but he writes very serious
book of economic analysis and so on and
so on then there is the old guy who is
far from simplification Frederic Shan
Shan and so on but they are totally
marginalized today in this politically
correct mainstream you know I I don't
keep well yeah your question seemed to
me to focus more on the pair the
peculiar relationship that I've noticed
and that people have disputed between
post-modernism and and neo Marxism and I
see the connection between the
postmodernist types and the Marxists as
a sleight of hand that replaced the
notion of the oppression of the
proletariat by the bourgeoisie as the
oppression by one identity group by
another token okay so but that but so
now look precisely and non non Marxist
lester patel well that that's the seated
i guess that's where we might have a
dispute because I think what happened
especially in France in the 1960s as the
as the radical Marxist postmodern types
like Derrida and Foucault realized that
they were losing the moral battle
especially after the information came
out of the Soviet Union in the manner
that it came out that yeah that the
whole blood is telling us yeah the whole
stell in this catastrophe along with the
entire Maoist catastrophe but they
didn't really have a leg to stand on and
instead of revising their notion that
human history and this is a Marxist
notion
be regarded as the eternal class
struggle between the economically
deprived and the oppressors they just
recast it and said well it's not based
on economics it's based on identity but
it's still fundamentally oppressor
against oppressed and to me that meant
that they smuggled the the the
fundamental narrative of Marxism and
many of its goals back into the argument
without ever admitting that they did so
now I've been criticized you know for
this opposition because people who are
post modernists a look one of the
hallmarks of post-modernism is
skepticism of meta-narratives it's like
I know that perfectly well and I also
know that Marxism is a meta-narrative
and so you shouldn't be able to be a
post modernist and a Marxist but I still
see the union of those two things in the
insistence that the best the appropriate
way to look at the view world is to view
it as the battleground between groups
defined by a particular group identity
nin dividuals defined by a particular
group identity so that the group
identity becomes paramount and then the
proper reading is always oppressor
versus oppressed with the secondary
insistence that's very similar to
Marxist insistence upon the moral
superiority of the proletariat that the
oppressors are by definition because
they're oppressed morally superior and
and there's the call for perhaps not
revolutionary change although that comes
up above but change in the structure so
that that oppression disappears so that
a certain form of equality comes about
now you argued that Marx wasn't a
believer in equality of outcome and I'm
not so sure about that because his
notion of the eventual utopia that would
constitute genuine communism was a place
where all class divisions were
eradicated but so does identification
well well there's at least an
implication of the most important of the
hierarchies had disappeared and so maybe
he had enough sophistication to talk
about other forms of hierarchies but if
if that's the case then I can't imagine
why he thought that the
utopia that would emerge as a
consequence of the elimination of
economic hierarchies would be a utopia
because if there are other forms of
hierarchies that still existed people
would be just as contentious about them
as they are now like we have hierarchies
of attractiveness for example that have
nothing to do with economics or very
little to do with economics and there's
no shortage of contention around that or
any other form of ability and so that's
why I associate the social justice types
who are basically postmodernist with
Marx post mow their post modernists with
Marxism it's the insistence that you
view the world through the narrative of
oppressed versus oppressor and I think
it's a catastrophe I think it's a
catastrophe and you appear it's no
career well just one sentence and then
he you can reply is so strange that you
mentioned for example somebody like
Foucault who for me that his main target
was Marxism okay for him represented in
in he and his his game was never a
radical change but and this is what I
don't like in this what you call
postmodern let's not call the Marxist
but revolutionaries it's this enjoying
your own self marginalization the good
thing is to be on the margin you know
like not in the center and so on and so
on
it almost made me nostalgic for old
communist who at least get the honesty
to say no we don't enjoy our margin
position we want to do something central
power I find so disgusting no it's no
wonder you don't get invited to lots of
places
yes no you you know you know Foucault
for me and bodies this logic of
revolution and by revolution he meant
any social train serious bet small
resistances and so on small marginal
places of resistance and so on and so on
so okay but let's maybe drop it here if
you want but since you are replying my
question
you should have the last word here I'll
stop with that let's move to the neck
we'll get back to these topics no doubt
as we move forward with the question so
I'm happy let that that particular issue
stop stop already do your Stalinist
manipulation and censor the questions
because this program that she described
to us through some screens questions and
so on I think it puts him to the one who
decides which questions are established
with the Putin are the real voice of the
people so hopefully we can trust him
let's move on from that and hurt this
evening we're talking about happiness at
least that's the frame of the debate
that we have tonight and you've both
been in your work and also tonight very
critical of happiness as mere hedonism
pleasure-seeking or even simply as a
feeling what does true or deeper human
happiness consist of and how is it
attained I don't well I don't I don't
first of all there's something you said
five minutes ago or so I think you were
still at the podium that I agree with
profoundly which is that happiness is a
side effect it's not it's not a thing in
itself it's something that comes upon
you it's like an act of grace in some
sense and myself even the your logical
undertone of what you say no no the
category of grace can be used in a
perfect eight a strange it is the
deepest I'm sorry okay good
well I would think I would think that we
could find agreement about that because
partly because of your psychoanalytic
background you know perfectly well that
we're subject to forces within us that
aren't of our voluntary control and
certainly happiness is one of those
because you cannot will yourself to be
happy you might be able to will yourself
to be unhappy but you can't will
yourself to be happy there are certain
preconditions that have to be met that
are quite mysterious in order for you to
be happy and then it has
and then maybe if you're wise you you
regard that as a like an in a minor
incomprehensible miracle that somehow
you happen to be in the right place at
the right time now I've made the case
that the most effective means of
pursuing the good life which is not the
same as pursuing happiness is to adopt
something like a stance of maximal
responsibility towards the suffering and
malevolence in the world and I think
that that should be pursued primarily as
an individual responsibility it's not
like I don't think that political and
familial larger organizations are
necessary but in the final analysis we
each suffer alone in some fundamental
sense and we have our own malevolence to
contend with in some fundamental sense
and the proper beginning of moral
behavior which is the proper beginning
of the right way to act in the world is
to take responsibility for that I think
you do what you can to conceptualize the
highest good that you can conceptualize
that's the first thing to develop a
vision of what might be and it has to be
a personalised vision as well as a
universalized vision and then you work
diligently to ensure that your actions
are in keeping with that and you allow
yourself on that pursuit to be informed
by the knowledge of your ignorance and
the necessity for acting and speaking in
truth and a fair bit of that I believe
is derived I think it's fair to say that
that's derived from an underlying
judeo-christian ethic and I make no
bones about the fact that I think of
those stories metaphysically or
philosophically or psychologically as
fundamental to the proper functioning of
our society in so far as it can function
properly and so it's not happiness it's
meaning and meaning is to be found in
the adoption of responsibilities and
then I'll close with this and
responsibility is not only to do what
you believe to be right that's not
because that's duty that that's not
enough that's sort of what the
Conservatives put forward as the
ultimate virtue which is duty it's not
that it's it's that you're
you're acting in a manner that is in
accordance with what you believe to be
right but you're doing it in a manner
that simultaneously expands your ability
to do it which means that you cannot
stay safely ensconced within the
confines of your current ethical beliefs
you have to stand on the edge of what
you know and encounter continually the
consequences of your ignorance to expand
your domain of knowledge and ability so
that you're not only acting in an
efficient manner but you're increasing
the efficiency and productivity and
meaningfulness of what it is that you're
engaged in and I think that and I
believe that the psychological evidence
supports this even the
neuropsychological evidence is that
that's when true happiness descends upon
you because it's an indication from the
deepest recesses of your psyche
biologically instantiated that you're in
the right place at the right time you're
doing what you should be doing but
you're doing it in a manner that expands
your capacity to do even better things
in the future and and that's that I
think that's the deepest human instinct
there is it's not rational it's far
deeper than that and it's something that
it's something that's genuine and that
exists within us and that constitutes a
proper guide if you don't pervert it
with this self-deception and deceit so
that's my perspective
yeah okay I'll try if you are stupid
enough to believe me to be brief yeah
first I like very much what you began
with this grace or whatever we call it
moment of happiness and I would like to
would you agree that the same goes for
love I think we have annuities and they
have it in French I don't know if in
other language they have it they use the
verb to fall in love which means it's in
this sense in some sense a fall you are
surprised you are shocked authentic love
I think is something very traumatic even
in this sense I always like to use this
example let's say you live a stupidly
happy life maybe one night stand here
and there you drink with French then you
fall in love passionately this is in
some sense a catastrophe for your life
all the balance is lost yes the world
yes you know so that's why Cupid has
arrows sorry
yeah yeah right yeah yeah absolutely so
but where I first second surprisingly
maybe for youth I agree with your point
about judeo-christian legacy for which I
am very much attacked euro centrist and
so on and so on but you know I wonder if
you would agree with it I will try to
condense it very much you know what for
me the deepest I simplified to the
utmost
something unheard of and I as an atheist
accept spiritual value of it happens in
Christianity other religions you have
got up there we fall from God and then
we try to climb back through spiritual
discipline whatever training good deeds
and so on and so on
the formula of Christianity is a totally
different one as we philosophers would
have put it you don't climb to God God
you are free in a Christian sense when
you discover that
the distance that separates you from God
is inscribed into God himself
that's why I agree with those
intelligent theologies like my favorite
Gilbert Keith Chesterton who said that
this the cross the crucifixion is
something absolutely unique because in
that moment of alien alarmist about God
Father why have you abandoned me for a
brief moment symbolically God Himself
becomes an 80s in the sense of you know
you get a gap there and that is
something shows absolutely unique it
means that you are not simply separated
from God your separation from God is
part of divinity itself and we can then
put it also in other terms maybe closer
to you like that that's right for me
happiness is not some blissful unity
with highest value it's the very
struggle the fall and so on and that's
why I hope we both worry about what will
this possibility of so called I'm
horrified with it what Ray Kurzweil
calls singularity and this blissful
state I preferred not to know but but
the final point very brief what I only
don't quite get why do you put so much
access to this we have to begin with the
person with personal trained I mean this
is also the second to reach one I don't
remember forgive me of your slogans in
your book you know first set your house
in order then but I have an extremely
common sense naive question here but
what is in trying to set your house in
order you discover that your housing is
in this order precisely because the way
the society is messed up which doesn't
mean okay let's forget about my house
but you can do both at the same time and
I would even say I will give you now the
ultimate example yourself
it that you are so socially active
because you realize that it's not enough
to tell to your to your to your patient
set your house in order
much of the reason of why they are in
disorder their house is that there is
some crisis in our society and so on and
so on so my reproach to you benevolent
would have been another joke to your
coffee yes please like individual or
social yes please because this is
obvious in extreme situation like I hope
we agreed to say to somebody in in North
Korea set your house in order no ha ha
but I think in some deeper sense it goes
all sorts for our societies I'm just
repeating what you are telling you see
some kind of a social crisis and I don't
see clearly why insist so much on this
choice because I will give you an
example that I think perfectly does it
how do we usually deal with ecology by
this false personalization you know they
tell you ah what did you do did you put
all the coke cans on the side did you
recycle old paper and so yes we should
do this but you know like I in a way
this is also a very easy way to describe
yourself or like you say ok I do the
recycling show up you know I did my duty
let's go on so I would love to say why
the choice there ok so well so first of
all I have to point out that it's you
have unfairly tasked me with three very
difficult questions and so I'm hoping
that I can this life if you said life is
the challenge in so so so so I'm going
to I'm hoping that I have the mental
wherewithal to keep them in track and
answer them in order but you can help me
if I stray I was very interested in your
comments about the about
Christ's atheism on on the cross that
final moment of atheism that that's
something I'd never thought about in
that Western Orthodoxy book no no it's
it's a very it's a very interesting
thought because what it what it it's a
really it's an unbelievably merciful
idea in some sense that the burden of
life is so unbearable it and you see in
the Christian passion of course torture
unfair judgment by society betrayal by
friends and then and then a low death
and so that's that's kind of that's
about as bad as it gets right which is
why it's an archetypal story right it's
about as bad as it gets and the story
that you described points out that it's
so bad that even God himself might
despair about the essential quality of
being yeah right right so and so that is
merciful in some sense because it does
say that there is something that's built
into the fabric of existence the tests
are so severely in our faith about being
itself that even God Himself falls prey
to the temptation to doubt and so that's
okay now this is where things get very
complicated because I I want to use that
in part to answer the other questions
that you answered look there's there's a
very large clinical literature that
suggests that if you want to develop
optimal resilience what you do is you
lay out a pathway towards somewhere
better someone comes in they have a
problem you try to figure out what the
problem is and then you try to figure
out what might constitute a solution and
so you have something approximating a
map right and it's a it's a tentative
map of how to get from where things
aren't so good to where they're better
and then you you have the person go out
in the world and confront those things
that they're avoiding that are stopping
them from moving towards that higher
place and there's an archetypal reality
to that it's
you're in a fallen state you're
attempting to redeem yourself and
there's a process by which that has to
occur and that process involves
voluntary confrontation with what you're
afraid of disgusted by an incline to
avoid and that works every psychological
school agrees upon that is that exposure
therapy the psychoanalysts expose you to
the tragedies of your past you know and
and redeem you in that manner and the
behaviorists expose you to the terrors
of the present and redeem you in that
manner but there's a great broad
agreement across psychological schools
that that's that works and my sense is
that we're called upon as individuals
precisely to do that in our life is that
we are faced by this unbearable reality
that you made reference to when you
talked about the situation on the cross
is that life itself is fundamentally and
this is a pessimism that we might share
is fundamentally suffering and
malevolence but and this is I think
where we differ I believe that the
evidence suggests that the the the light
that you discover in your life is
proportionate to the amount of the
darkness that you're willing to
forthrightly confront and that there's
no necessary upper limit to that
so I think that the good that people are
capable of is actually it's a higher
good than the evil that people are
capable of and believe me I do not say
that lightly given what I know about the
evil that people are capable of and I
think that I believe that the central
psychological message of the biblical
corpus fundamentally is that that's why
it culminates in some sense with the
idea that it's necessary to adopt it's
it's necessary to confront the devil and
to accept your what would you say your
the unjustness of your tortured
mortality if you can do that and that
and that's a it's a challenge as you
just pointed out that that's sufficient
to challenge even God himself that you
have the you have the best chance of
transcending it and living the kind of
life that will set your house in order
and everyone's house in order at
same time and so I think that's even
true in states like North Korea and I'm
not asking people to foolishly immolate
themselves for pointless reasons you
know if I'm a when I'm working with
people who are clinic clinically and
they have a terrible oppressor who's
their boss at work I don't suggest that
they march in and tell them exactly what
they think of them and end up on the
street it's not helpful you know and so
the pathway towards adopting individual
responsibilities happens to be a very
individual one but I do believe that the
best bet for most people is to solve the
problems that beset them in their own
lives the ethical problems that beset
them that they know are problems and
that they can set themselves together
well enough so that they can then become
capable of addressing larger scale
problems without falling prey to some of
the errors that characterize let's say
over optimistic and intellectually
arrogant ideologue very brief let me
close with one thing one of my favorite
quotes from Carl Jung it's actually a
quote that I used at the beginning of my
first book which was called maps of
meaning was that if you take a personal
problem seriously enough you will
simultaneously solve a social problem
and this bears on on your point because
it's not like you're a small family even
the relationship between you and your
wife is immune in some sense to the
broader social problems around you and
so let's say right now there's
tremendous tension between men and women
in the West and that's certainly the
case given the divorce rate let's say
that would be some evidence and the
later and later stages that people are
waiting to become in - you know enter
into permanent relationships there's a
there's a real tension there and then if
you do establish a relationship with a
woman or a partner but we'll say a woman
in this particular case you are
instantly faced with all of the
sociological problems in a microcosm in
that relationship and then if you work
those damn problems out if you can work
them out within your relationship then
you can get some insight it's not
complete insight but you can
get some partial insight into what the
problem actually is and get the
diagnosis right and you've moved some
small measure forward in addressing what
might constitute the broader social
concern and what's even better you're
punished for your own goddamn mistakes
and that's another thing I like about
the idea of working locally is that you
know if I do broad scale social
experiments and they fail it's like well
tough luck for the people for whom they
failed but if I'm experimenting on
myself within the confines of my own
relationship and I make a mistake I'm
going to feel the pain and then I and
that's good that's just it but it also
gives me the possibility of learning and
so I believe that you do solve what you
can about yourself first before you can
set your family straight and before you
should dare to try to set the world
straight otherwise you degenerate into
this kind of you already talked about it
this shallow moralizing did this well
I've divided my goddamn coke cans up and
now I can spend more money on new
packaging at the supermarket which is
exactly what the psychological research
indicates that people do if they perform
a casual moral action they immediately
justify committing a less moral action
because they've put themselves in a
higher moral place and you might if you
were real pessimist you'd say well
that's why they performed the action to
begin with I think that's often true
that's associated with that shallow
moralizing are we are we too much in
this direction or or again I will put in
my stalinís terms would you go as far as
to say who needs the people we talk for
the people and not better than the
people now because I don't want to take
too much of the time for the public but
you know what interests me would you
then agree because this is how Google
reads the story of the fall that fall
really is phallic culpa in the sense
that for Hegel before the fall we are
simply any
it's through the fall that you perceive
goodness as what will drag you out of
the fall so in this sense fall is
constitutive of the very you know it's
not you fall from goodness you fall and
that's the dialectical paradox your fall
recur actively creates what you fell
from as it were and that's the tough
lesson for trip moralist to to to a cap
but you know where I see very briefly
maybe a counter question what fascinates
me we didn't cover this I didn't cover
this but speaking about ideology
would you agree what fascinates me more
and more is not big ideology in the
sense of projects and so on in our
cynical era people claim all we no
longer take them seriously and so walk
but and here for me social dimensions
enter enters even our intimate space
implicit belief ideological pressure
positions why not which we embody in our
most common daily practices for example
probably some of you already know it I
will nonetheless repeat a very shortened
version I was occupied at some point by
the structure of toilet in Western
Europe I noticed this special yeah yeah
specificity of German toilets where you
know the feet doesn't discreet doesn't
disappear in water it is there exposed
that you smell it and control it for
whatever and immediately associated it
with German spirit of poetry and
reflection and so on it's a bad joke but
what I'm saying is that in a sense and
I've spoken with some specialists I was
so intrigued by of how do you construct
toilets and they admitted it there is no
direct direct utilitarian reason it is
as if even in something as vulgar as
going to the toilet ideology indeed
deeper sense is there another thing that
at the same level repeat one of my old
roads that fascinates me intensely it's
how it's not just as superficial
psychoanalysts claim we pretend to be
moral to believe but deeply we are
cynical egotist quite often in today's
times we think that we are a free
permissive and so on but secretly we are
dominated by an entire pathological or
not even often pathological structure of
prohibitions and so on so we may and
this is what interests me so much
precisely in today's time where and this
is how would you agree we would explain
the simple facts which may appear we're
that cow
apparently they so they tell us we live
in permissive times take your pleasure
may enjoy it but at the same time there
is probably so some clinicians are
telling me more frigidity and importance
than ever that the lesson of
psychoanalysis I hope we agree is not
this vulgar one you are cannot perform
sexually you go to psychology
psychiatrist he teaches you how to get
rid of authority and so on it's a much
more complex situation it's and this is
what interests me immensely all this set
of implicit beliefs how you don't even
know but you you know I will repeat the
story that half of you know and you my
favorite that niels bohr anecdote you
know he had the house outside Copenhagen
the quantum physics guy and he had a
horse too superstitious about his door
yes and then a friend asked him but do
you believe in it why do heavy dare and
he said of course not and a scientist
why then do you have it there because I
was told it works the idea is it
prevents evil spirits I enter the house
it works even if you don't believe in it
now that ideology today that ideology
today fundamental
so so so I want to solicit from you to
tell a joke I don't you CD I think I
think that people are are possessed by
ideas that aren't theirs there yeah and
their personalities that aren't theirs
and that's the great psychoanalytic
insight it's not ideas it's
personalities it's way worse than than
ideas and some of those personalities
might be the ones that are associated
with the idea that freedom is found in
maximizing hedonistic moment-to-moment
pleasure or something like that which
sounds like freedom like for me one of
the things that I suggest to people is
that they watch themselves as if they do
not understand who they are or what
they're ruled by and then notice those
times when they're there they're where
they should be that and that's back to
our discussion about meaning rather than
happiness it's like you'll see there are
times that in your life where you're
somewhere or you've done something and
all of a sudden you're you're together
you're you're where you should be your
conscience is not disturbing you you're
you're you're not proud of what you did
because pride is the wrong term but you
understand deeply that you've done
something that you should have done you
might not understand why you might not
even understand what it is but the study
of that can help elucidate the
difference between what actually
constitutes you is a very difficult
thing to discover and what constitutes
the accretion that characterizes you
because of the well let's say your
intense your intense proclivity for
socialized mimicry and so you know your
I don't mean you personally but people
are amalgams of everything they've seen
and everything they've ever seen they've
watched yeah yeah yeah and everything
they've read and and to integrate that
and define the
the truth that constitutes that
integration is incredibly difficult
endeavor and one of the reasons why in
12 rules for life for example I
suggested that I'll try to tell the
truth or at least don't lie is because
one of the ways apart from pursuing what
you what appears to you to be meaningful
one of the ways of escaping from that
possession by the kind of ideology that
you're describing which is like an it's
like a it's like an unconscious of
unidentified axioms it's something like
that even though they take personified
form they're like personalities is to
stop saying things you know not to be
true it's a nice pathway forward it's
the original rule was tell the truth and
I thought no that's not any good because
you're so biased and limited and
ignorant and possessed that you don't
know what the truth is and so you can't
be asked to tell it but everyone does
have the experience of being about to
say or do something that they know by
their own they know as deeply as they
can know anything about themselves that
that utterance or action is wrong and
they still do it now my suggestion is
try to stop doing that and one of the
consequences well you can try in small
ways like you might not be able to
manage it in big ways but now and then
you know you're tempted to do something
that you know to be wrong and you could
not do it and if you practice that you
get better and better at not doing it
and that means you lie less and you and
you take the easy route out less and you
pursue hedonic pleasures that cost you
in the future less you start to
straighten yourself out you take the
beam out of your eye
that's essentially what you're doing and
over time you have some modicum of hope
that your vision will clear up and
you'll be able to see the proper pathway
forward and that's part of the process
of redemption and it seems to me to be
in your grasp you're capable of doing
that you have a conscience it does
inform you from time to time correctly
about the difference between good and
evil that the consequence the knowledge
the consequence of the fall that you
described which I think you described it
very eloquent terms and that you can
slowly make your way back to the
straight and narrow path that's
characterized by maximal meaning but
also see that this instinct of meaning
is a sophisticated one it's not that I'm
making a case for the individual like
Iran makes a case for the individual
that's not it I'm making a case for
individual responsibility that's not the
same thing it's like there is something
that's good for you but it has to also
be good for your family if it's just
good for you that's not good enough and
if it's good for you and your family and
it's not good for society then that's
not good enough either and so the
responsibility is to find a pathway that
balances these things in a harmonious
manner it's like a I got a lot of this
thinking from Jean Piaget and his idea
of equilibrated States right is you're
attempting to find something like a game
that everyone is willing to play that
can be played in an iterative manner and
not degenerate well hopefully actually
ascend if that's possible hopefully
become a better and better game across
time and I do believe that I do believe
that you can do that I do believe that
you can do that if you're guided by
truth and I do believe that the pathway
to that is the phenomenology of meaning
and then the secondary consequence of
that is if you do that now and then you
might be happy and then you should be
profoundly grateful because happiness as
we already agreed upon is something like
a grace what basically it
again my pessimism comes here I agree
with you but the danger here here they
all agree can massively enter you
describe a nice situation you are
tempted or or dirt or whatever to do
something that you know it's wrong but
so-called totalitarian ideologies step
in at this point and try to present to
you that the true greatness is to do
what you individually think it's wrong
for the higher course you know who says
this wonderfully horrible Heinrich
Himmler of SS no no sorry seriously he
knew the problem German officers must do
horrible things
Childress and his solution was double
first to let them know as he put it
somewhere every idiot idiot okay
ordinary man can do something great
maybe not all sacrifice himself for his
country but his reply was his point was
but it takes a truly great man to be
ready to lose his soul and to do
horrible things for his country and I
read some good memories of relatively
honest communists who broke down when
they were sent to the countryside from
in in early thirties and this is what
this is what they were told by operatic
you will see horrible things children
starving and so on remember there is the
higher course and your highest ethical
duty is to is to overcome this small
bourgeois sentimentality and so here I
see the danger of again my pessimism
false meaning which can massively cover
this false narrative second thing also
the solution by I wonder if you share
this pessimism of mind another one by
Himmler you know what was his sacred
book I read he all the time had a
leather-bound copy in his pocket Bava
got Geeta he massively he said his
problem was this one he puts it
perfectly not the officers have to do SS
horrible things how to enable them to do
it without themselves becoming horrible
beings his solution was oriental wisdom
to learn to act from distance I am not
really there and this was the shock of
my life based on this do not the book I
found a book the Gaiden wrote many books
Bryan Victoria Zen at war it's a
shocking book especially horrible for
many so called entire a centrist who
blame our monotheism is guilty of
everything we need oriental him a dead
book is about the apart from a couple of
exceptions the behavior of Zen Buddhist
community in Japan in the thirties early
forties not only they totally supported
Japanese expansion into into China they
even provided properly Zen Buddhist
justification for it for example the one
you know who did this no you are not as
old as me I remember him DT Suzuki the
great pre yeah but okay he was doing
this in the sixties but as a younger guy
he was fully supporting Japanese
militarism and one of his justifications
was this one the advice of Japanese
military to them to support Zen Buddhist
training because he says it's one of the
most horrifying thing that I've ever
read he said sorry don't take it
personally but let's say an officer
orders me if I were to tell this to you
it would be too obvious so I'll pick you
I have to kill you stab you with mine
and he said if I remain in this
illusionary self then I feel responsible
I kill you but he says if you are
enlightened by Zen Buddhism then you
know there is no substantial reality you
become a neutral observer of your
I've just a flow of phenomena and you
tell yourself it's not that I'm killing
you but in the cosmic dance of phenomena
my knife is floating and somehow your
knife Falls you know what I'm saying
this I'm not disputing some spiritual
greatness of Zen Buddhism I'm saying how
even the most enlightened the spiritual
experience can serve a terrible course
now because we're running very quickly
out of time and it's clear that this
conversation could go for a very long
time
I'm going to ask one representative
question here and give you each one
minute each and that is and that is
simply this coming from online what is
one thing you hope people will leave
this debate with and why Jordan
I I hope they leave this debate with a
belief in the power of communication
between people with different views no
that's
in there there there is this there is a
growing idea on college campuses tell me
if I go over my minute that there really
is no such thing as free speech because
people are only the avatars of their
group identity and they have nothing
unique to say and besides that there's
no communication across boundaries of
identity or belief and and I think that
that's an unbelievably dangerous and and
pernicious doctrine and I think that
people of goodwill despite their
differences can communicate and they can
both come out of that communication
improved even though there might be some
dissent and some some dissent and some
dissent on the way and so that's what I
would hope people would come out
I will be more concrete even politically
there is today so it appears this big
conflict between all that postmodern
stuff that you oppose and this alt right
and so on
I hope sincerely that we made at least
some people to think and to reject this
simple opposition there are quite
reasonable but the only alternative to
all try it is not political correctness
and so on and I know I'm speaking not
for you but for me please if you are a
leftist don't feel obliged to be
politically correct things please don't
be afraid don't be afraid to think and
especially would you agree one great
version of not thinking it's cow
immediately if they don't agree with you
you are labeled a fascist but that's the
laziness people find something they
don't agree with instead of thinking
they think about something we all agree
was a bad thing up you're a fascist and
so on
you know it's not a simple as death even
Trump of whom I'm deeply critical no I'm
sorry to tell you yes is the catastrophe
in the long term and so on but he is not
a fascist you make it all too easy to
play these games
I just want not a positive result but to
shatter you a little bit to to make you
think I have always felt that the
greatest conversations are unfinished
ones please join me in thanking Slavoj
Zizek in Jordan Peterson for a great
unfinished conversation
right but we survived thank you Father
so we waved everyone all right good
night everyone